you ready sure
your weapon look here the ultimate
forged and fired matchup you are the
forest and fire Champion two Champion
plays in a deadly weapon Showdown it
will kill 20 blades 20 Champions you
decide the winner forged in fire Madness
the Potter I'm Travis Wertz I'm 34.
typically I'm known for building
Grinders winning forged and fire the
first time was a lot of fun because so
many of my customers said I didn't know
you could do that I thought you just
made Grinders that was a good feeling
the Potter was a unique Gauntlet weapon
developed by the marathas of central
India this double-edged weapon had a
long flexible blade over four feet long
the Potter was so distinctive it was
featured in the cult classic film Willow
instead of featuring a Garb like most
sorts it had a steel Gauntlet that would
cover the hand in sometimes even the
forearms with their arms strapped inside
of the gauntlet the user would not have
the use of their wrist therefore a
soldier equipped with a Potter needed
experience in using such a unique weapon
while the Potter was commonly used by
mounted wires its design allowed even a
soldier on foot to strike from a wider
variety of dangles compared to a
conventional sword
what the hell is a Potter
before Viking Store was on my list of
things to make and this is I don't even
know what this is
the scissor my name is Don halter I've
been a Texan all my life I plan on being
a Texan the rest of my life I got three
degrees and nuclear engineering I found
my calling cleaning up radioactive
material decontaminating stuff we had a
lot of Homer Simpson t-shirts
wielded by Gladiators in ancient Rome
the scissor was an ideal weapon for the
bloodied battles that had suited the
Coliseum Arena the Contour of the sharp
crescent-shaped blade was optimal for
slashing and stabbing while the armor
encasing the forearm offered protection
Gladiators who used the scissor were
also known as sasortes they could
swiftly brandish the weapon in the heat
of battle due to its surprisingly
lightweight dual block and cut
capabilities of the scissor 3 the user's
other arm for another weapon or Shield
giving the user the advantage of
multiple ways to attack
can't go wrong with 5160.
the pot is a broadsword blade that
linked the sword blade to the forearm to
generate power through the elbow and
shoulder I can I can I'm starting to see
this being
this is going to be some you can just
mess up some
I'm ready to quench my blade
well here we go what I consider the most
important part of this build is the
hardening of the blade if it's soft it's
not going to hold an edge if you hit
something you don't want to stay bent I
would like to do some testing
ah
that's tough man I still got to build my
whole Gauntlet so if I make 14k to make
it wider just make this loop I make a
bigger a 16 gauge I just dial the whole
thing
I have the Fist of the gauntlet I welded
that to the arm piece of The Gauntlet I
welded that to the guard
to the hand piece I still got to put a
strap in I want a freaking sheepskin in
it all right let's go time is running
out
that's gonna make a mess but I don't
care
oh this is gonna suck God damn it last
10 minutes was a [__]
all right all right that works
go ahead I wish I could take that
discoloration off I'm out of time right
okay then I'm done
[Music]
I'm not really familiar with a gladiator
scissor but since it is armoring I've
been doing armoring for about 25 years
I'm sure I can overcome any challenges
that come up for it I'm using a coarse
wrought iron combined with high carbon
steel to make a composite welded blade
I have no idea what that came off of
Just
hey man we're Texas we're bigger and
better and our blades are better
my whole Gauntlet section is done in
three pieces the only thing I have left
to do is to make sure all the parts fit
back together there's no warps in there
that I can't take out from my head first
time
I'm trying to get the main cone put on
it's driving me nuts
there's a slight warp in it
keeps catching on the inner layer all
right one more time
that was the pain
we don't want a triple holding this that
would really suck
so I want to make sure nothing's going
to Rattle loose when the judges start
hitting stuff with it that would hurt so
the final test
it rubs on a knuckle slightly but you
know to be honest I didn't even notice
that until afterwards because I was just
having too much fun swinging and cutting
things with it
to see how much lethal damage your
weapon can do I will deliver some
killing blows on this big carcass Travis
you're up first ready sure
[Music]
Travis your design of your Pata feels
good when you're thrusting it went all
the way through the carcass on a
diagonal slice almost cut all the way
through the pig carcass
overall sir your blade will kill
good job thank you blade Smiths this is
a kill test to see what can a lethal
damage your weapon will do I will take
your scissor and I will deliver killing
blows on this ballistics dummy done your
turn let's have some fun let's do this
[Music]
foreign
what I like about your weapon is that
it's in Lime with the handle on the
initial cut here it lacerated right
through there and in this backhand hook
your Edge is deep to go in here and
right into that cavity your weapon will
kill thank you test your blade strength
we're going to put it in our Vise and
then Flex it both directions to 20
degrees
if your Blade's strong it should return
to true
Travis you're up first are you ready yep
here we go I'm pretty nervous right now
anytime somebody shoves your tip in a
vice and goes bending on it you can't
help but think something bad is going to
happen
20.
looks good so far
clay
all right Travis you know everything is
still right and tight up here your
connection to the gauntlets very solid
good job thank you now the scissor was
used in gladiatorial combat for both
attack and defense now to test the
strength and durability of your weapon
we'll clamp them into our mechanical
device here the Blade's going to come
down and strike the armored cuff of your
weapon twice and then your weapon is
going to be launched into this
breastplate so don you ready I'm ready
all right let's get you strapped in
foreign
I'm having a hard time finding where the
sword hit it and there's one teeny
little Mark
and the Blade's still tight on that edge
is still a razor blade there's no
rolling at all very well done it's nice
thank you
see how sharp your weapons are I will
take your Pata and I'll deliver three
sharp blows on these meat carcasses
Travis you're up first you ready might
as well
I feel pretty good going into the
weapons testing I know my blade has good
geometry and it's comfortable
[Music]
well done
okay Travis very nice clean lines with
your blade on the motion it's got great
recovery a little bit heavy for the
gaunted there but it is wicked sharp
your weapon a little cut thank you this
is the sharpness test to test the
sharpness of your Edge I'm going to
attack our sand band here several times
done you ready I'm ready
[Music]
God I like the way this is set up
tighter around the arm
right here at my hand
my knuckle is just pounding into the
side
you can see it's slashed pretty easily
on the arm and then on the forward punch
didn't quite get a slash I was looking
for all in all though did the job thank
you
now it's your turn which weapon will you
choose forged in fire Madness
[Music]